we were talking about uh the woke stuff
and I was thinking about this earlier I
think the reason that we're seeing the
success in the boycotts
it's not just because and I think it's
mostly not because people had some
Epiphany and they woke up and said hey
what was his bed I think what's
happening is young people are more
likely to be they're slightly more
conservative and you're seeing people in
our generation and younger now becoming
dominant forces in the market as we're
entering our mid to late 30s into our
40s
and we are buying things as we would
normally do so in fact I don't know how
much of this anti-work phenomena is
actually related to an a red pilling as
it is related to young people who
despise wokeness now having more money
and then when target has been doing the
pride stuff for for a decade nobody
cared yeah and it is a combination of
now they're doing the kids stuff they
may have done it for a long time but now
people are concerned about the kids
stuff but now I think you're looking at
I talked about how Republicans were
having more kids
in it was like three to four for every
three kids the Liberals were having
there were four kids conservatives were
having then we see that that was in 2000
that then it was reflected in uh pure
research showing that gen Z is slightly
more conservative makes total sense then
when it comes to spending patterns you
will see the exact same thing so whereas
Target for the Boomers the Gen xers and
the younger Millennials 10 years ago had
no problem putting a pride merchandise
the younger generation now coming in and
our generation now getting more and more
money
we are not we're rejecting it all and
it's hitting their bottom line really
hard I I mean I'm thrilled that it's
finally it seems to have met a tipping
point where like they can no longer just
to continue to shove this garbage down
our throats and it's not a moment too
soon I I I'm just curious to see like
how bottomless is the ESG well how how
many resources can the BlackRock State
Street Vanguard Central Banking cabal
you know a line to support these
institutions that have ultimately been
doing what Larry Fink demanded of them
Larry fig has been for years has been
imploring and not imploring demanding
that every single business that he's
going to give a dollar to implement this
type of nonsense so if they turn around
and then abandon them well then all of
the other corporations that are
witnessing that have to say to
themselves oh it doesn't matter if we
play by the rules if the consumer turns
against us ultimately they're the the
power broker here I was saying this I
think it was when I was talking to Vivek
Rama Swami that the Bud Light thing
happened because it's a millennial woman
who gets it gets this High Roll in
marketing and then says we go woke
but there's I think what what I missed
in at that period when I was saying yeah
the wokeness is not like it's not the
people who work in these companies are
becoming woke it's that woke people are
now getting jobs in these companies what
I didn't catch was the consumers don't
care or want this stuff and so
the infiltrators will come into the
institutions Implement these policies
it'll work for a little bit and then
once the other side of the coin the
consumer comes in they reject all of
those things and those institutions
begin to fail I sure hope man I think I
think that's the only way forward is
that Anheuser-Busch not just Bud Light
in terms of a brand but Anheuser-Busch
has to be devastated by this decision I
mean so like an Institutional American
or uh company it's been around forever
right to see that fall apart because of
these decisions made by someone at that
level who was hired is is extremely
small but understand this we have seen
Bud Light sales drop precipitously over
the past two months and it's it's
looking like it's bottoming out it's not
when the when the boycott first started
we're talking April 1st El Mulvaney does
this thing this video then you get sales
dropping by single digits double digits
and now nearly 30 percent
it's been more it's Memorial Day weekend
it's May it's summer so what's actually
happening is there is a spike in Bud
Light sales
Bud Light sales are actually going way
up
that happens every summer spring into
summer people are buying more and more
beer grilling hanging out outside if
we're seeing it still going down from
last week to this week only a couple
points
if this was a normal year with no
boycott you would actually see an
inverse picture of the sales leveling
and then spiking in May so my point here
is
if it were not for the boycott their
sales would be up double digits the fact
their sales are only down a couple
percent means in spite of the summer
months hitting and people and Memorial
Day Weekend people celebrating holidays
their sales are still dropping after
this summer I think it's going to drop a
lot harder yeah no I think you're
exactly right and uh this this video has
gone viral it actually is a couple
months old I remember I tweeted it out
but it has been going viral again over
the past 48 Hours where Larry Frank
Larry Fink who's the CEO of BlackRock
nine trillion dollars under management
insane uh is being interviewed and he's
talking about forcing behaviors quote
unquote forcing behaviors we have to
force behaviors and what he's what he's
not just implying but saying overtly is
that we will force these companies to do
away with their fiduciary responsibility
to their shareholders because we are
bigger than the shareholder we are
ultimately the the only thing that
matters it's not your consumers it's not
your your mom and pop shareholders it's
not your employees it's not none of that
matters it's the big Financial arms at
the end of the day they get to dictate
your behavior and that is their world
view as to why this has been implemented
is that they were going to force
behaviors like implementing diversity
Equity inclusion in brands that were
extraordinarily masculine historically
which makes no effing sense whatsoever
but they started with Gillette and then
they just worked down the line and
finally the American people have had
enough thank god well look at uh look at
Disney and what's going on with Disney
or even Marvel this happened to Marvel
like eight years longer than this has
been going on here when Marvel when we
talk about uh woke women who end up in
middle management positions and then
start pushing ideas onto these companies
that don't jive with your audience
Marvel yes exactly but Marvel a brand
that has a strong Market in the average
middle-aged American male and they'll
always be able to sell Comics to them
but they're always looking for the
mythical you know Target the mythical
new demographic that's going to somehow
magically expand their consumer base
right and it never works out that way
because it's just that's not how that
type of business works at least not in a
creative sense you can't start selling
these things uh in a sense that it's it
doesn't feel authentic and it doesn't
come across authentic because it doesn't
match with the rest of the brand right
and remember they're owned by Disney so
it doesn't even matter so it's a funny
microcosm because Marvel Comics is a is
a rounding error to a company like
Disney the movies obviously are enormous
but the comics are a rounding error
because it's such a it's such a smaller
brand nowadays because so many less
people are actually buying physical
comics and for them now you look at the
movies and like what Tim was saying
about things bottoming out I think the
Little Mermaid for instance is like made
like 120 million in its opening weekend
but when you account for inflation it's
far below what it would have been just a
couple of years ago obviously before
inflation skyrocketed back upwards and
that's another example of what is they
you get people in middle management
companies you know middle management
positions at these companies and they
start pushing these agendas whether it
is Dei or in a lot of cases for this
stuff they're just telling them like
look this is good marketing this is
where we want to go BlackRock and all of
these companies obviously agree and they
think why wouldn't this be a good idea
well it doesn't jive with the brand just
like it doesn't with Bud Light just like
it doesn't with Gillette and we see
evidence over and over again that it's
not working but they keep doing it so
that's the hard part for me so what
happens do they find the millennial who
is not someone who grew up with wokism
and is in middle management and swap
them in or do we have to wait for the
newest generation of middle management
to rise up and graduate you have you
have actual you know Comics like Eric
July's Isom which is trying to create a
competitor to to Marvel
um you know I have no idea if he'll be
successful obviously I'm rooting for him
because he comes from my ideological
camp but there's going to be a lot of
competition that tries to replace some
of these goliaths but the problem is
that you can't get financing at the
highest levels to compete with these
guys because if you want that financing
you have to do the same crazy stuff to
compete so you have to go Dei you have
to go ESG so the only way you can
compete is to be someone like Tim Poole
or Ben Shapiro daily wire you have to
like get capital from other people that
are already already successful telling
the truth and bucking the woke Trend and
you guys have to combine your resources
and then use your platforms to compete
it's very challenging like that's why
people people get it totally wrong when
they go well if this was so bad then all
of these companies would go bankrupt no
they exist still because there's no
competition because ESG is a is a tool
to create and and harness and inculcate
the the oligopoly that exists that's why
you don't see competition and this is
why ultimately there ought to be
anti-competitive investigations into
this entire operation because as far as
I'm concerned it's got to be Criminal on
multiple levels
but there probably never will be because
they own all the politicians yes yes and
then aliens will be announced again and
we'll just forget all about it I'm
telling you if we hold out long enough
they'll tell us some real Secrets I
really want to know where Hoffa's buried
can we just hold out for that yeah stay
keep putting pressure on the Biden
situation to find out about Hoffa they
have to confirm every single conspiracy
theory before they admit that Joe
Biden's crooked yeah it's like oh man do
you have any conspiracy theories left
we've already admitted to everything the
frogs are being turned gay and and
they're eight eight uh sub floors under
the Denver Airport all the good stuff
that's where Hoffman is under the Denver
Airport that's what I heard yeah Denver
Airport one really gets me because they
were like just talking about this one
I've been thinking about it for a little
while uh it got introduced to me and now
I can't stop I was talking about it on
PCC on Friday uh I love that they were
like we have a working airport but we'll
build this really expensive one with a
baggage shipping situation that actually
we don't need like the city of Denver
should be irate if they just wasted all
this money on an airport which everyone
I know who those numbers like we hate
driving through the Denver airport to
pick people up like and how does a story
like that not turn into a conspiracy
theory we built this massive place
underneath the airport and then decided
no we're not used to use it like no one
is mad about that
interesting I like it I like the
paintings oh yeah you've seen the
paintings at Denver Airport oh yeah so
creepy yeah and then the horse that
killed its artist and then they put it
up anyway crazy thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time